MARK MANDEL: This is Agones--
Scaling Multiplayer Game
Servers with Open Source.
I hope you're in
the right place.
If you're not, that's OK.
You can leave.
I'm Mark Mandel.
I'm going to talk
for a little bit.
Then I'll be joined on
stage by Carl Dionne
from Ubisoft and
then after that,
Edward Chin from Supersolid.
So if you want to talk about
open source and multiplayer
games and dedicated
game servers,
you should hopefully
be in the right place.
Cool.
Before we get started, that's
about me, but who cares.
I'd like to know a little
bit more about all of you
so that we can sort of
tailor this a little bit.
Hands up, people here who
work on multiplayer games.
Excellent.
You're all in the right room.
Awesome.
People here who are familiar
with Docker or containers?
A lot of you.
Badass.
Awesome.
People here who are
familiar with Kubernetes?
Lots of you, not all of you.
That's OK, totally fine, too.
Awesome.
All right, so
that's pretty good.
Before we get stuck into things,
marketing gave me the slide.
This is good.
No, it is good.
Actually, I've been
super proud of the work
that Google is doing this year
across multiple product areas.
We really have basically
a suite of products
that work across
the games industry
to help you create,
connect, and scale.
There we go.
I said the words.
We're good.
Let's move on.
All right.
So let's talk about multiplayer
games and all the good things
therein lie.
So I want to talk about very
specific types of multiplayer
games.
Obviously, multiplayer is a vast
and varied ecosystem of things.
Primarily what I want to talk
about is your fast-paced online
multiplayer games--
your Fortnites,
your Overwatches,
your Rocket Leagues,
that kind of stuff.
We're going to actually see
a demo a little later on.
There is an open-source
game called Xonotic.
It's a fast-paced FPS.
Anyone here know Xonotic?
People who know Xonotic because
they've seen my talks before?
Yeah, same group.
OK, cool.
No, it is actually a
really fun little game.
We're going to use
that as a demo,
but it is very much
that type of game.
We're going to just set some
basic foundational stuff
for people who aren't as
familiar with multiplayer
games, but for some
of you I'm guessing
these will probably be
things that you're already
somewhat familiar with.
So when running fast-paced
online multiplayer
games, usually, and a fairly
prevalent way of doing this--
and there's a variety
of ways-- is doing it
through what we would commonly
refer to as a dedicated game
server or an
authoritative server.
So essentially what this means
is you have a set of clients,
say four people playing
a game, and they
connect to some individual
simulation server that
sits somewhere on the internet.
It's controlling the
physics of the game,
what players are doing.
It's essentially the
authority of everything that's
happening inside the game.
And usually players
are sending in things
like, hey, I did this thing,
like, I fired a rocket,
or, I'm moving forward,
or, I'm running now.
And it's the job of the
dedicated game server
to do a lot of the work
to determine exactly
what's happening
and send information
back to those players to
let you know, yes, you
did hit this player,
or, yes, you scored
a goal, that kind of stuff.
There's a couple of
good reasons for this--
and this could be its own
other talk in and of itself--
the two big ones being that one,
having a dedicated game server
gives you a bit more
control over what's going on
and can give you some
avenues to stop cheating,
because people are horrible
and they like to hack stuff.
And the other thing is that,
unfortunately, we can't
control the speed of light.
It would be really
nice if we could.
So having control over
the geographic region
of where you put your
dedicated game server
means that you have some
control over how much lag
there is going to be between
players based on where
they are around the world.
So if we want to play a game
and we're all in San Francisco,
we want to put our game
server in San Francisco, which
is awesome.
We probably don't want
to put it in Australia.
That would be bad, because
it's very far away,
and then we get big lag time.
So that gives us some control
over what it is we want to do.
So how do we run these?
Let me put that on full screen.
That's better.
So traditionally,
how do we do this?
This is probably fairly
familiar to a lot of people.
We might have a couple of
people who want to play a game.
They usually connect to
some kind of matchmaker,
and the matchmaker's
job is to group people
by social graph and skill
level and all that kind
of good stuff.
And then usually, they talk
to some kind of bespoke server
manager thing,
wherein it says, cool,
I know about a whole bunch of
VMs, or something like that.
And I need to go find some
CPU resources and some memory
resources and spin up this
game server for a person
to play on and find a port
and do all that kind of work,
and do it across,
potentially, thousands
and thousands of machines.
And then once I've got that
game server up and running,
I grab the IP and port or
ports that it's running on,
and I pass that all the
way back to the players
so that they can connect
directly to the game.
And we can now play a game.
That's a lot of work.
So the part that
Agones and the things
that we want to talk about
today do is really this part.
How do we do the
orchestration of game servers?
How do we find the right
amount of resources
to run our game servers on?
How do we know that
they're up and down?
How do we make sure that we
have lots of them sitting
there waiting to do stuff?
How do we do that whole process?
That's kind of a very
foundational task
that we all kind of
need to do if we want
to run dedicated game servers.
And I think it's also kind of a
solved problem that lots of us
have done over and over again,
so having a single solution
is super nice.
So speaking of single
solutions, a few of us
came together and
looked at this and said,
OK, there should be a standard
solution for us doing this.
This shouldn't be something
that we all reinvent
the wheel over and over again.
It's a foundational piece.
It's nothing actually
that secret sauce
about how we do stuff for game
servers and running multiplayer
games.
The actual games themselves and
the pieces of the games, that's
the secret sauce.
So we came together,
built out a project,
and Carl's going to talk
a little bit about that
a little bit later, the
collaboration between us
and Ubisoft.
But basically, yeah,
we wanted to build
an open-source platform for you
to run, host, and orchestrate
your dedicated game servers
across large clusters
of machines.
So my job here today is kind
of to show you how some of that
works and give you some
background on that.
And my follow-up people
will tell you a bit more
about the experience.
So first things
first, some of you
are familiar with Kubernetes.
For those of you
who aren't familiar
Kubernetes, Kubernetes
[INAUDIBLE]..
They're an open-source
project that originally
got started by Google but
has involvement from Red Hat
and a bunch of very,
very, very large companies
and has been used a variety
of places, including
GitHub and eBay and
been running Pokemon Go.
And you can read
a bunch of stuff.
It has become, I
would like to say,
almost a-- probably a
fairly standard de facto way
of running large scale
distributed systems
across large
numbers of machines.
If you're not familiar at
all, just think of it as a way
to programmatically
and declaratively say,
I want this software to run
over lots and lots of machines.
At a base level,
that's what it does.
There's more nuance
to it than that,
but that's basically
what it does.
And we're able to leverage
this to run game servers.
So there's a few
really important things
here that I think
are worth mentioning,
even if you're not that
familiar with Kubernetes.
One, Kubernetes, it's
an open-source project.
Quite obviously, I
work at Google Cloud.
We have a managed version
of Kubernetes called GKE,
but Kubernetes itself
is open-source and will
run pretty much anywhere.
You want to run it on us?
Perfect.
You want to run it
on your machine?
Fine.
You want to run a single cluster
inside your QA workstations?
Perfect.
You want to run it
across multiple clouds?
Awesome.
So anywhere that
your players are
and you want to be
able to reach them,
you can put a
Kubernetes cluster,
which is great because
sometimes players end up
in strange places
around the world,
and you need to run your
infrastructure there.
The other thing that I
really like about this
is also that it simplifies
a lot of your systems.
So I say this
because Kubernetes is
great for running your
microservices and that kind
of stuff, your marketplaces and
your auth, and that's awesome.
But usually what I see
when I talk to game studios
and development
shops is they have
one system for all
their back-end services
and then one completely
different system for all
their dedicated game servers.
My perspective
here is if you can
run the same platform
for both, suddenly
you can run the same tools.
You can use the
same infrastructure.
You can use a lot of the
same ecosystem tooling
that you use across the board.
And so suddenly,
you're like, OK,
I don't need to relearn
a whole new system
to do these sort of things that
are usually fairly interlinked.
Finally, if you're not
familiar with Kubernetes,
that is an ecosystem
that has ridiculously
blown up over the last
three or four years.
I can literally say that
when we built Agones,
we were standing on the
shoulders of giants,
because there are so many
people working on this project
and so many people working on
projects around this project
that it enables us to leverage
a whole bunch of stuff.
So anyway, enough preaching.
Let me show you basically
how this stuff works.
So potentially unsurprisingly,
the first building block
of everything is we put
stuff in containers.
This means that if you
want to run a game server,
we really aren't restricting
you about how you do it.
As long as you can put
things in container,
you're pretty much good to go.
So as long as you can put
stuff in a Docker container,
it's great.
We do have an integrated SDK,
so there's an integration point
with your game server itself.
We have some pre-built
SDKs that are gRPC
based, which is just the
way we do our PC calls.
But if you don't like it,
you can always use REST,
so it's fine.
Basically, the short
answer is if you
want to integrate with your
engine, we can find a way.
It's fine.
It's all good.
There's lots of ways
we can make that work.
And this is really
just so that we can see
what your game server is doing.
Is it healthy?
Has it started yet?
Is it ready to take players?
The game server can
access its configuration
for Agones, all the good things
that it needs to be able to do.
So let's actually
look at how we get
game servers running on this.
So Kubernetes itself, like
I said, is declarative.
Basically, we tell
it to do something,
and we trust that
the system does it.
And one of the lovely
things about Kubernetes
is it also enables
us to extend it.
So by default, Kubernetes comes
with a bunch of stuff that
works great for web servers.
Fire me up 10 of these,
and make sure they stay up,
and also put a load
balancer in front of it.
That's great.
That doesn't work
necessarily for game servers,
so when you install
Agones, suddenly it
has this new verb inside
the configuration yaml
files that we set up
called GameServer.
And now it understands
how game servers work.
So here, as I said,
we have a game server.
We're able to give it a
name, or we can actually
have Kubernetes create the name.
There's all sorts
of good stuff here.
We can specify a port policy.
So Kubernetes itself
doesn't do dynamic ports,
Agones will do that for you.
So it'll do the routing for
the ports for your game servers
as they come through
without you having to worry
about doing any of that work.
And then you can
basically specify
a set of containers, or
just a single container
for a game server,
that runs your example.
Here we're running Xonotic.
It's a simple template
that we have here.
If you aren't familiar
with Kubernetes,
this is actually, down
here, a full pod spec.
So if you want to do volume
mounts, or config maps,
or multiple containers,
or anything like that,
you totally can.
It's all available to you.
So this is cool.
For sake of time, I'm not
going to show a demo of this.
This is just running an
individual game server.
Basically, you can spin
it up and spin it down.
That's cool.
But what we really
want, and I think
for a lot of game server
workloads, what we actually
want is large groups
of game servers.
So sometimes game servers take
a little while to spin up.
Sometimes they're a little slow.
It's OK.
So if you had a set of 100-- no,
let's say 10,000 or 50,000 game
servers-- or less,
which is fine too--
just sitting there waiting
for players to come in,
then we can manage that here
with what we call fleets.
So if you're familiar
with Kubernetes,
rather than having
pods and deployments,
we have game servers and fleets.
So a fleet is basically a
specification of game servers,
but we just say how
many of them we want.
So here we are saying
we just want two.
We don't have that
many players yet.
We just have two people.
It's fine.
And down here we specify what
our game server specification
looks like.
It's just an extension from
there, nothing too crazy.
So now we can have big
fleets of game servers, which
is super cool.
We can scale them up
as much as we need,
but we need a way to
atomically access a game server
within that fleet.
So we need to be able to
say, hey, I have a player--
say it's come for a matchmaker
or something similar.
I need to be able to be like,
that whole big group there,
please just give
me one, and give me
one in a way that makes sense
for a variety of reasons.
So we have this concept of
what we call allocations.
And allocations are
actually kind of special,
and they're kind of awesome.
Allocations are
primarily-- I think
you'll find you usually do
this through an API call.
Everything I've shown you here
is through yaml files, which
is the declarative nature.
Everything I do here I could
also do through an API call
to the Kubernetes API.
I don't have to do
it this way, this
is just easy to show for
demonstrative purposes.
But I'm able to do an
allocation with this.
So if I wanted to say, I want
out of the Xonotic fleet,
I'm going to send
it an allocation.
I'm going to do--
here I'm actually--
I have a variety
of things I can do
with allocations.
But here I'm just
saying, out of the fleet,
Xonotic, please give me a game
server and set it to allocated.
And allocated is special.
Allocated is that
special status that
says, players are playing
on this game, please
do not delete them.
Because players
get mad if you just
decide to delete
games for some reason.
And they post stuff on
Reddit, and it's just no fun.
No one likes that.
And this is probably one
of the core things that
makes Agones Agones
is that it understands
that transition of state between
hey, I have a game server.
No one's playing on it.
Who cares if it dies?
To, hey, I have a game server.
Players are playing on this.
This is now really
important, and please do not
remove this in any
way, shape, or form.
So allocation is the thing
that allows us to do that.
And we can actually do
a whole bunch of things
with game server allocation.
We can do preferred sets.
We can do multiple requirements.
There's lots of good stuff here.
But essentially, we're
just doing some label
matching here wherein we
can have arbitrary key value
pairs and whatnot.
So I thought I'd do a
bit of an extended demo
and show you it in action and
make it a little less abstract.
So hopefully nothing goes wrong.
Yes.
Awesome.
So I have a Kubernetes cluster.
It has about 20 nodes
on it, give or take.
This is the command
line tooling.
So it's all set up.
I don't have Agones
installed, so let's actually
install Agones.
We're going to use a
package manager called helm
to install Agones.
And I'm going to install it--
Agones system.
That should probably
not be there yet.
And it'll be Agones/Agones.
So I'm going to install the
production version of that,
the most recent release.
And that's pretty much there.
That's pretty much what I
have to do to install it.
There's a few different
ways we can do it.
If we want to have
a look, there's
a few components it installs,
a few different things there.
Here we have the controller
system as well as
some latency measurement
stuff that we have installed.
But that's all good.
That's pretty much what
I had to do to install.
So if I want to
create a fleet, we
can use the same yaml
file we did previously.
Again, we could do
this through an API.
We could do this a
bunch of different ways.
So examples xonotic fleet.yaml
and we can enter that here.
So this is quite cool.
So we installed Agones and that
installed those extensions we
were talking about previously.
So now we can
actually say things
like, hey, Kubernetes, show
me the game servers that
are in your system and show
me the details about them.
That's something that Kubernetes
didn't know about before,
but now it's integrated
directly in our tools.
They're spinning up on, I
think, some new clusters.
They'll come up in a minute.
Of course, it's a
demo so something--
they're just pulling down.
That figures.
They'll come up in a minute.
But we can see things here.
So we can see what address
and what port they're on.
They're currently scheduled.
They'll kick over
to ready in probably
about a minute once
everything's happy.
And we can mess around
with this now and see it
in a variety of ways.
If we want to have a look at
it as a fleet, for example,
we can see here that there's
two currently desired,
and they'll soon be ready.
The Xonotic image is
like a gig and a half,
and so it takes a
little bit sometimes
to pull down to a machine, but
it'll be there in a minute.
And we can see some
various things on here.
So if we want to scale
this we can do so.
So let's just scale the fleet.
kubectl fleet.
I'm typing down here
so it's always fun.
kubectl fleet xonotic.
I know what I did wrong, sorry.
Scale.
There we go.
Now we get the
[INAUDIBLE] completion.
Xonotic replicas.
We'll say 200.
So that will start coming up.
So now if we say get fleet--
oh, good, the two
finally came up.
That will come up pretty
quick, but we can see
that's going to start to grow.
If we want to have some fun--
that should be green now
because we've actually got that.
We can start actually
seeing dashboards for--
is that going to work
for me or did that crash?
Of course.
Demos, can't trust them.
There we go.
Awesome.
So that's now
working [INAUDIBLE]..
We have pre-built Grafana
dashboards and hooks
into Prometheus.
So we use a library
called OpenCensus
for doing our
statistics and metrics.
So you can use either Prometheus
or Stackdriver if you want,
or pretty much anything that
OpenCensus will support.
So if we want to have
a look here and have
a look at our number of
game servers, for example--
that is tiny and you
can't see anything--
you'll start to see the number
of games servers start to grow.
This is usually running a little
bit slower than what actually
is happening, and we
can start to see things
like how fast our game
servers are coming up.
We can start to see rates
of what state they're in,
what fleet numbers
they have, how they're
distributed across our cluster.
There's a variety of
different types of statistics
that we're able to
take advantage of,
which is really, really nice.
They're starting to come up now.
We have about 100 or so.
That's pretty nice.
So we can do all sorts of
fun things here as well.
So if we have a look at
our fleet-- there we go.
We have about 106 ready.
That's much better.
They're coming up pretty quick.
So let's actually
do an allocation,
and we'll play with that.
So kubectl create -f examples
xonotic gameserverallocation.
So again, you would probably do
this through a Kubernetes API
call, but we're
going to just do this
through this just for
demonstrative purposes.
And I'm going to tell it--
that -o yaml basically
says the result that
you're going to send back
to me that usually would
be JSON just put it
out as yaml on screen so
we can see what it's doing.
So we can run that, and that's
going to basically give us
back an allocation.
And the bit that we care
about is really this here.
So it's going to take one
of those game servers out
of that set, looks
through them all,
basically look at how
many we have available,
and grab the one that
is ready and sitting
there waiting to be played on.
And give us back the address.
So we can see here that
that's on 35.236.122.
That's the game server name
that we had previously,
and there it is
state is allocated.
So let's play a game.
Is that going to open
on the right window?
It is, yes.
Awesome.
I'm just going to move
that over a little.
Perfect.
Let us see if I can type this
correctly over my shoulder.
Yep, I can't.
122 169 [? colon ?] 7353.
Let us see how the
internet is here.
That is actually good.
My mouse has disappeared.
Here we go.
So I'm just going to
play that in the corner.
So this is me trying
to play Xonotic.
Oh, I see.
It actually still
has the settings
where I dropped all the weaponry
so I could take screenshots,
but that's all right.
But this is me playing
Xonotic on Agones running
on a cluster in the cloud.
Basically, this is running
on a GKE cluster on US West.
We have some bots
running around.
I am terrible, clearly,
because apparently I'm
underwater for no apparent
reason, which is fine.
Where am I?
I'm also trying to
play on a trackpad.
I'm going to blame it
on the trackpad mostly.
Come on.
There we go.
Thank you.
I'll let someone kill me.
Where is one of those?
There we go.
So we have a few people
coming and playing against me.
But yeah, this is
running up on Kubernetes.
It's all working
really, really well,
and we're able to play a
game, which is super nice.
I'll show you some other
fun things while we're here.
So you can start to see some
more fun things in the graphs
now.
They take a little
bit of time, but we
have 199 already sitting there.
You see up in the top left-hand
corner that's all green now.
We can start seeing
some more things here
about our rate of
stuff coming up,
as well as how many already.
We also have autpscaling
capabilities,
which I'm not going to
talk too much about today.
We have graphs of that.
All that sort of metrics.
All the stuff that you just
need to have to run game servers
and make that really
important stuff without you
having to do the work to write
all this plumbing type of code.
So there's a lot of really
cool stuff inside Agones.
So hopefully that
gives you a bit
of an idea of how that
whole system works.
We come over here again too.
We can also have some more
fun because we have some time.
I can scale this back down.
So if I say scale
fleet xonotic replicas.
Say I want to make that zero.
That's going to start
deleting game servers,
but we have one game
server that's allocated
and so we don't want
that one to die.
And so what we will
actually see is yes,
it will go and get rid of all
the game servers that we would
have had previously,
but it won't
touch that one game server
where we have players on it.
So that's super important.
So even if we are
editing our fleets
and we have a rolling
update rolling through,
which is something
we support, or you
want to scale a fleet to adjust
workloads based on, say, maybe
you have less players
coming in, you always
know that your players are
safe on that game server.
See how quickly that comes down.
There we go.
And so we have that
one allocated now.
That never went away.
It always stays there.
That's super important.
Cool.
So that was me showing you
how some of that stuff worked.
That means now that
when you have players
that want to play a game,
rather than connecting
to some bespoke
system they can take
some sort of custom
matchmaker, potentially Open
Match for some strange reason.
Also a fun project we work on.
But they can talk directly
to the Kubernetes API.
They can reuse all the stuff
that Kubernetes' API gives you.
As soon as we install
Agones the tooling changes,
the API changes.
It understands how to
manage all these things.
And then the
Kubernetes API can be
like, hey, Agones, I'd really
like a game server to be
allocated to me please.
So cheers, thanks.
Appreciate that.
And then the information can
be sent back to the players
and the players can play a game.
And so you really can just focus
on what that game server is
doing and how it works,
rather than having
to worry about how it
spins up and spins down.
All right.
Enough of me.
I'd like to introduce
Carl Dionne to come talk
about how things are
going over at Ubisoft.
[APPLAUSE]
CARL DIONNE: Hi.
For some reason, Mark and
I have similar t-shirts.
So I'm Carl.
I'm Director of
Development at Ubisoft.
I'm responsible for the
multiplayer products,
multiplayer services
in the online group.
So that's mainly the network
code, matchmaking, as well as
the server allocation products.
So I work at Ubisoft.
You probably know Ubisoft.
We're the third
largest publisher.
We have a bunch of people.
14,000 employees
and that's growing,
so it's a pretty big company.
You probably know our games.
So today I want to talk a
bit about why we actually
were interested to
collaborate on Agones.
And let me start
by talking a bit
about the change that's
happening in the industry
today.
If we look back, it's
not that long ago
releasing the game used
to be the objective,
and now it's just
only the beginning.
Players are expecting to see
their games as a service.
It's not just a box
product anymore.
They want to see a service.
They want to see a game that
keeps changing all the time.
They want to be
surprised by new content
whenever they log onto the game.
So that game as a service
trend is something
that continues and accelerates.
And I think that when you look
at cloud gaming, for example,
to me, it's just a
natural extension of this.
That's the way that players
wants to have their game.
So let me talk a little
bit about what impact
it has on our games.
So when we look at the game
[INAUDIBLE] the game client.
So what's a game client?
Well, it's a thick client.
It can be pretty
big, like when we
look at the latest
Assassin's Creed,
let's say 42 gigs client,
so that's pretty big.
That client is going to connect
to an ecosystem of services
that will be running.
So that includes stuff like
matchmaking, challenges, stats,
whatever.
And as we are building
rich games as services,
it means that
ecosystem of services
is becoming richer and
richer because that's
one good place where
we can deliver value
and content to our players.
One thing that we see
as well is if we're
going to build
that type of games,
it means that we
need to have content
that will be available for
the players for a long time.
So an easy way to
make a game that
will have hundreds
of hours of gameplay
is to make it a
multiplayer game,
so that's the reason why we
see a lot of multiplayer games
nowadays.
And so typically it
means that you're
going to need to have a
game server to actually host
that multiplayer application.
Now that's going to come
with a number of challenges.
First, we need to be agile.
We need to be able
to adapt super
fast to the needs
of the players,
and that's true across
the entire ecosystem.
We know how to be fast at
deploying new services,
but we also need to be able
to do it through the game
client and the game
servers as well to be
able to deploy new content.
Another challenge
that we have, as well,
is the question of scale and
the question of proximity.
We want to make sure that
these game servers sit
very close to the players
because if latency is high
that's going to have an
impact on the performance
that they see.
When you think about
scale, game servers
are pretty CPU intensive.
To give an idea, at
Ubisoft we currently peak
at about 100,000
virtual machines
to run our game servers.
But when look at that, like
having 100,000 virtual machines
across dozens of data centers,
that's a pretty big number.
That's going to be close to the
capacity of many data centers
that you see.
So that makes your typical
blue-green deployment
quite a big challenge.
So in that context,
making that type of game
is becoming
increasingly complex,
and I think that collaboration
is something that is important.
It's a nice slide, eh?
It's a bit cheesy.
I think that we could
make a nice poster,
like you have these nice
motivational posters.
But seriously, collaboration
between our teams at Ubisoft,
collaborations
between the brands,
and collaborations with
other people in the industry
or outside of industry,
I think is something
that's very important.
And that's basically
how Agones was born.
So a while back--
it's about maybe a bit
more than a year ago--
we knew that Stadia was coming,
and I was talking to Mark.
And for some reason,
if we look at Stadia
and we have the game's
client of running on GCP,
it makes sense to have the
server running in GCP as well.
And so I was talking
to Mark and said,
hey, what are Google's plans
regarding game servers?
And we chatted for
a little while,
and we realized that we had
a very nice collaboration
opportunity, where basically
we could say, well,
let's put together the knowledge
of Google for what it means
to be able to scale and
deploy containers in scale,
with Ubisoft's expertise of
what it takes to actually
build and manage game servers.
And that's basically
how Agones was born.
So it's an open-source
project that
makes it possible to deploy
game servers at scale
across Kubernetes.
So it actually was a nice
collaboration [INAUDIBLE]..
So one thing that I really
like is since Agones is based
on Kubernetes, what do we get?
Well, we actually have
a lot of flexibility
because now we can actually
deploy these game servers
across different
type of clusters.
So we can go, for example, to--
we can deploy them
with physical clusters,
and that's a good
way to save the cost.
And that's important.
And when we have
a spike, then we
can actually go on the cloud
to be able to handle the burst.
So Agones is something
that's part of a wider
ecosystem at Ubisoft.
It's part of a [? complete ?]
ecosystem made up
of hundreds of applications
and microservices
to manage the online
at Ubisoft, and I
think it was a pretty good
example of collaboration
between two companies.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
EDWARD CHIN: Hello.
Hi, I'm Ed.
I'm one of the
co-founders at Supersolid.
I apologize for not
being on brand today
with the Agones T-shirt,
but maybe later.
So in the next
five to 10 minutes,
I'm going to tell you a
bit about one of the games
that we have in development.
I'm going to go
through why we decided
to use Agones, how
we're using it,
and also a bit about our
experience with it so far.
So quickly, first a
bit of background.
Supersolid, we're a
team of about 40 people
who are based in
London in the UK,
and so far we have
these five games.
So our first two games, Super
Penguins and Pororo Penguin Run
are both infinite runners.
We've got Adventure Town, which
is a town building light RPG
game, and then our two
most recent games are
Food Street and Home Street.
They're resource management
simulation games.
As you probably
noticed, none of these
are multiplayer
games, or at least not
real-time, synchronous
multiplayer games,
but that is what we currently
have in development.
I can show you a bit
more about this game.
It's called Snake
Rivals and here is
a short teaser, which I might
need Mark to play for me.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
Great, thanks for that, Mark.
Thanks.
So that's all our latest game.
It's out later this year.
It's called Snake Rivals.
It's our first real-time,
synchronous multiplayer game.
The idea is that there are
50 players all in an arena
at once, and we've got
these three different modes.
There's a classic mode, which is
kind of similar to an IO game,
if you like.
So players come in and the
session ends when they die.
And then we've got
two other modes--
a gold rush mode and
a battle royale mode.
In gold rush it's more timed,
so in more strategic game play
you're trying to make kills
or steal kills, and then
at the end the player who
has the most points wins.
And the third mode,
battle royale,
I am assuming that everyone
knows what that is.
And basically, the last
surviving player wins.
So about I guess 12 months
ago, a little less than that,
we decided to make this game.
The first question
I guess was, well,
how are we going to build it?
And quite quickly we
decided to use Kubernetes,
so the big question
for early research
was what implementation of
Kubernetes we wanted to use.
We settled on GKE, which
is Google's implementation
of Kubernetes.
We did that for a few reasons.
I think we basically
tried it out
on a few different services.
With GKE we found it
was just the easiest
to set up and get running.
There were also a few other
advantages that we liked.
The ease of using
the GCP services,
such as load balancing as well.
That was pretty important to us.
Debugging live code, easy error
tracking of live incidents,
and also we found it's
also relatively cost
effective, which
is also something
important to consider.
So having decided to use
GKE, we found that we also
had three key requirements.
This is stuff that I guess
Mark went through earlier,
but it's pretty important
for these multiplayer games.
So the first thing
is that we've got
to be able to start up
game servers on demand.
So in the endless
mode, for example,
when the arena fills
up with 50 players
we need to start a new arena.
So we need to be able to
start a new game server.
And for the other
modes, when players
want to start a
new game, again, we
need to start up game
servers on demand.
And when the games are
over, when they're finished,
we also need to be
able to shut them down.
The second requirement, which I
think Mark touched on as well,
is to be able to protect running
servers from shutting down.
So this is pretty key.
So if a service gets
updated, for example,
you don't want
your games servers
to shut down because everyone--
all your players
currently playing--
will get kicked off their game.
And then your Google
Play rating goes down,
and that's always
a terrible thing.
Then the third
requirement is, of course,
the scale based on demand.
So number of players and
their location as well.
And what we found
was Agones just
helps solve all of
these issues for us,
and that's the main reason
why we decided to use Agones.
Moving on to exactly
how we're using Agones.
So this is what's going
on with Snake Rivals.
So when you start the game, the
client asks for the game mode.
So whatever game mode
the player asks for.
That then goes to the Google
Global Load Balancer--
not the easiest thing to say--
and that asks for
the matchmaker.
Also, it selects
the best cluster
for the client to connect to.
The matchmaker then finds
that specific game mode,
a game for that to join,
and Kubernetes via REST API
gets the list of game servers.
And that's managed by
Agones, which maintains
the pool of game servers.
The matchmaker then decides
from the list of game servers.
And again, via REST
API with Agones,
we mark that
selected game server
as allocated so that importantly
it doesn't get destroyed.
The matchmaker then
returns that one game
server to the
client and the game
starts and the
player obviously has
a great time playing the game.
And when that game finishes,
again via REST API and Agones,
we then mark that
server as shutting down.
And that's at a
pretty high level
how we're using GKE and Agones.
And so finally, it's a question
on how we're finding it,
and it's been
pretty great so far.
We've seen that it's a pretty
supportive environment.
So there's a Slack group
that's pretty responsive.
There's a Google Group.
There are community meetings
that happen quite regularly.
It allows us to
influence the roadmap
of what's being produced,
prioritization of that as well.
And then obviously we're able
to report any bugs that we come
across, so that's been great.
We've also, through this,
built a great relationship
with Google, and that's
given us great access
to training materials,
so courses and Kubernetes
workshops as well, which has
been really positively received
by our developers.
So thanks for that.
We've also had access to a
production readiness review,
and that's been really useful.
So they assess the
game architecture,
and they give suggestions
on how to operate
at Google's standards.
That's the SRE methodology.
All of this is just
super important to us
because I think all
game developers here
just know how hard it is
to develop a hit game.
And once you have that
you just want to make sure
that everything scales
properly and all
your game servers
are up and running.
Finally, we probably have
to say something negative,
if there is anything
negative at all.
The only thing is to point
out it's an alpha service
so you might get what you
expect from alpha services.
If a feature gets deprecated you
might have to code around that,
or you might be working
away at a feature
and then you realize
that actually that's
what they're building next.
But you know what?
It really doesn't matter to us.
The communication
has been great so we
avoid a lot of these issues,
and also if we weren't using it
we'd really have to build
it ourselves anyway.
So for us it really
has been a no brainer.
So to sum up--
with GCP, with GKE,
Agones, it's really
allowed us to be able to build
Snake Rivals with a relatively
small team, probably just
two server developers,
in under 12 months.
So that's been great.
Thanks, and look out for Snake
Rivals coming later this year.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so much,
Ed and Carl, for joining us.
We want to make sure we have
plenty of time for questions
as well, but some things
to talk about as well.
So before we wrap up there's
some things I want to mention.
So I gave you all a brief
overview with Agones.
If you haven't looked
at it in a while
it's definitely increasing
at a fairly rapid rate,
which is really great.
But there's a lot
of other features
that we didn't get to touch on
today, including A, the fact
that it works cross
cloud providers.
We work against
vanilla Kubernetes.
That's very important to us.
We want to make sure
it works everywhere.
We didn't talk about
autoscaling, but that
is something that is
ingrained and inbuilt.
So we have fleet autoscaling.
We work directly with the
standard Kubernetes autoscaler
as well, so cluster autoscaling.
Hello, GDC.
So that's all available as well.
We have a suite of
local developer tools.
So for example, if you don't
want to run a full Kubernetes
cluster on your machine.
You just want to do
some light testing.
We can do some SDK local
tooling, things like that,
to make that a little
bit easier for you to do.
And I showed you some of
the metrics and dashboards,
but there's a whole suite of
more metrics and dashboards
that you can use.
And that's an
ever-growing thing that we
want to keep expanding
on because it's
the second day and the third
day things that really get you.
It's the stuff
[INAUDIBLE] making
sure you know exactly
what's happening
in your system on the launch
day and then the day after that
and after that that really
gets you as you go through.
On the roadmap coming forward,
I would actually say--
I just want to be
very clear as well--
on the roadmap we are very
directed by our community.
If you're here now and your
interested in the project,
I would definitely love to say
come in, try it out, provide
feedback.
There are a lot of
features that are getting
developed right now that
maybe a month ago we
wouldn't have even looked at.
But because the
community got involved
we started to look
at it and be like,
oh, this is a thing
that's really important.
A lot of us have shifted
gears, changed priorities.
[? We'll ?] [? work ?] with
other people who are using
the tooling to really
build the things they need,
so that's definitely
a big thing.
Things highlighted.
We've done a bunch of
performance improvements
in the last few months
that have been great,
but we're looking to do some
more that are coming up.
Again, like I said, more
metric collection and display.
Ops is hugely important.
We've got some commercial
engine integrations.
Right now if you want
to run Unity or Unreal
you have to hook
into our REST API.
It's not the
cleanest, but we want
to have some stuff
out of the box.
You can still do it.
It's fine, but we want to make
that a smoother experience.
Multi cluster.
Multi cluster is
also front of mind.
Right now it's fairly focused
on individual clusters.
We have some design
tickets around right
now for doing multi
cluster allocation and then
some other things around
that we're looking at.
Potentially working with some
of SIG multi cluster things.
There's a lot of work going
on in the multi cluster
space for Kubernetes, so there's
plenty of space there to grow.
Windows hosting is something
I also get asked about a lot.
Generally speaking,
we are leaning
on the work of the
Kubernetes community,
so if anyone's
here from Microsoft
please keep doing the good
work you're doing with Windows.
Thank you.
We appreciate that.
As soon as that stuff bubbles
up into the Kubernetes ecosystem
then we're able to do that.
We realize that's important,
both from a development
perspective because a
lot of us work on Windows
and we just want that
short iteration time,
but also there are people who
run production [INAUDIBLE]
on Windows and that's
totally cool as well.
So we want to do that.
Definitely [INAUDIBLE].
If you're interested in Agones,
we actually released this just
the other day.
So if you want a very quick way
of getting an Agones cluster up
and running for
test purposes, you
can actually go to the
Google Cloud Marketplace.
You'll see there's some
documentation there,
and you can go
search for Agones.
Go through and it will
create a cluster for you.
You can actually do the
installation right there.
It's basically a
one click install.
I would say it's generally
used for testing purposes.
We have some hardening rules
that we do in production
that we couldn't quite do
yet in the marketplace,
but we'll get to
it at some point.
But if you just want to be like,
hey, how does this thing work?
How can I use it?
Let me try it out.
This is a great place to
start and get your feet wet.
Lastly, I will say very quickly
before we get to questions--
we have plenty of time for
questions, which is great--
my business cards are
up here at the front,
along with a whole
bunch of Agones stickers
if people like stickers.
I hear developers like stickers.
My business cards are
here, so please feel
free to come up and grab one.
If you haven't got
questions right not,
but you think you might,
say a week from now,
two weeks from now, a month from
now, please grab my details.
Come join us on Slack.
Come get involved on GitHub.
We'd love to have you.
But if you want to
learn more, the website
is up there at agones.dev.
Please follow the Agones
Twitter [INAUDIBLE] Twitter.
If you want to learn more about
Kubernetes, kubernetes.io,
and Google Container Engine.
Before we wrap up and open
the floor up to questions,
thank you all for
coming in and hopefully
enjoying yourself with us.
I know all your
time is valuable,
so I appreciate you all coming
and spending your time here.
So without further ado, if
anyone has any questions,
I would love to hear them.
If you want to come up on
stage too we'll do that.
Questions?
Over there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: Two questions.
MARK MANDEL: So the question
was, does the Docker container
set any hard limits?
Not really, no.
As your Docker containers get
larger they can be unwieldy.
There are some
strategies we do have
that we're starting to
talk about internally
about how to share
assets between containers
and how to load them up quickly.
We can do some in-memory
mapping type things.
That's another area we want to
explore as we go forward too.
A lot of people in
development just
build really big containers,
like 3 gig, 4 gig, containers,
and it's fine.
They just transfer over the
network a little bit slower.
You had another
question, I know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
Perfect.
AUDIENCE: The automatic port
allocation that you showed.
Can you just talk a
little bit about that?
MARK MANDEL: OK, so
the question about how
we do port allocation.
Basically, the way
we have it set up
is for each game server
it sits essentially
within its own
network namespace.
So what we do is the
container starts up
and it's whatever
port that you tell
that it's going to
start up on, so they all
start up internally the same.
We set up a Kubernetes
host port, basically,
which what that does is it'll
set up an IP tables route that
runs through the node and then
directly into the container.
We found through testing
it's like worst case
scenario-- [? and ?]
[INAUDIBLE] doesn't
hit that very often--
about half a millisecond.
But it means then you can
still run sidecar containers.
You can still run other
services alongside it
and know that is contained
within that network namespace,
so you can do some really
nice stuff that way
and it was a nice
trade off that way.
I think that it was you
who had a question next.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I just think
I just missed what you're--
is that free to download or
do I need to buy the trial?
MARK MANDEL: For
the marketplace?
Oh, that's a good question.
How do I work it
on the marketplace.
So if you want to install it
on Google Container Engine,
we have a $300 free trial that
is valid for up to 12 months,
so you can go use that.
If you want to do it locally
you can do it locally.
If you want to use--
there's a couple of
local Kubernetes tools.
Kind, K-I-N-D, or Minikube, so
you can install either of those
locally and then install Agones
on that and that's not going
to cost you anything.
AUDIENCE: I was thinking
trying to test a multiplayer
game for my own game
for just future--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So you could do either of those.
You could test it
locally on your machine
or run a trial account
on Google Cloud.
AUDIENCE: I was also
thinking about that I'm
attending a school at the
[INAUDIBLE] University
and [? it's ?] just testing the
different computer that, hey,
can you hit me or something.
And then, boom, [INAUDIBLE]
you or something.
[INAUDIBLE] planning for.
MARK MANDEL: There was I
think someone over there.
I'm staring this way.
I need to turn that way next.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So it seems like a lot
of the architecture
we just talked about
is useful in an example
where you spin up a pod,
you allocate the players
and it tears down in a
traditional multiplayer
setting.
But how does this
work where you might
need interpod communication
in something like an MMO
where instances are just
constantly being spinned up
for different players
in different zones
and that sort of thing.
MARK MANDEL: That is
an excellent question.
So how does this
work [INAUDIBLE]??
So we have been
relatively focused
on more of a
session-based thing.
I definitely want to explore--
or I think we definitely want
to explore, I should say.
We definitely want
to explore how we can
support more MMO type stuff.
The nice thing about
Kubernetes is the way
it's set up with
its networking model
from a foundation is that all
pods can talk to each other.
As long as you have the
IP address of the pod
you know you can
actually communicate
within the networking
system within the cluster,
so that sort of stuff
is available to you.
But I actually do want to
explore more if there are
things that we can do at more of
that foundational orchestration
layer of how can we-- and I
don't know exactly what that
looks like, but how can we do--
help you with geographic
splitting or that kind stuff.
That being said, there's nothing
that necessarily stops you
from doing that.
You can leave these up for as
long as you like if you want.
They don't necessarily
have to come down
in three minutes or
20 minutes or an hour.
As long as you want to do
a little bit of extra work
over the top you can still use
them for doing MMO type stuff.
There's nothing inherently there
that stops you from doing that.
AUDIENCE: So I have one more.
So you talked a little bit
about hosting on Windows.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious
about how much exploration
you've done in
terms of nodes that
are Windows in
Kubernetes clusters,
but then more importantly
Windows containers.
Specifically because we work
on the tools for PlayStation
development--
MARK MANDEL: Got it.
AUDIENCE: --where most
of it happens on--
MARK MANDEL: I have not
explored that really at all.
There is a lot of work that is
happening with running Windows
containers inside Kubernetes.
I'm not an expert on that area.
There's a whole SIG for it.
There's a whole
special interest group
for Windows and containers.
As far as I understand
it, it is coming.
They're working on it.
It was required-- there
was some requirement
for some early release
type stuff on Windows
to get the Windows
containers support needed
for Kubernetes [INAUDIBLE]
coming through,
but it is coming.
It's just a question
of when it gets done.
AUDIENCE: Is the answer just
go talk to Microsoft guys?
MARK MANDEL: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Is the answer just
go talk to the Microsoft guys?
MARK MANDEL: Go join--
there's a SIG Windows
group in Kubernetes.
The way the actual open-source
project is structured
is they have special interest
groups for different areas.
So you can go on Slack, you
can go on the mailing lists.
They have regular meetings.
So basically, you can go see
what the structure is there
and everything is available.
It's all open.
AUDIENCE: OK, awesome.
Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: It was over here.
I've been facing
on the other side.
AUDIENCE: How does this
fit in with Stadia?
MARK MANDEL: How does
this fit in with Stadia?
Actually, that took longer
than I thought it would to ask.
The short answer here
I think is Stadia's--
I'm not going to talk
on behalf of Stadia
because that's not
the product area.
But the short answer
here is we talk a bit
about our network essentially.
And so if there are instances
which you are using Stadia
and you want to have a dedicated
game server, running it
inside Google's network
is ideal because we
don't have to go outside.
We're inside our own network.
Our product manager
was talking about this
earlier this morning.
There's a lot of inherent
speed and cost savings
you can do there.
So there are some
instances where
you may want to run a
dedicated game server,
but we allow you to do
that and so awesome.
That's the short answer.
I figured I would get
that question like first.
We have a couple of minutes.
Someone over there.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for giving the talk.
You mentioned getting some
of the metrics out of Agones,
but what I'm more
curious about is managing
the complexity of Kubernetes.
Are there any good
tools for pulling out
stack traces of server
crashes or things
like that that you
know of presently?
MARK MANDEL: So
generally speaking,
as long as anything goes--
any text goes-- actually,
here's an interesting question.
How do you dump your
server traces now?
Is that just straight to a text
file, does it commit to logs?
Are you doing heap dumps?
AUDIENCE: Logs that are
then [INAUDIBLE] external--
MARK MANDEL: As
long as any log--
so speaking of-- let me
try this sentence again.
Speaking for Google
Kubernetes Engines,
and generally speaking
on Kubernetes as a whole,
if you spit your logs
out to foreground--
so basically to standard out--
then they get
aggregated [INAUDIBLE]
central logging service.
If you're running on
Google Kubernetes Engine,
it's already set up so that
our Google Container Engine--
sorry, that was the old name.
It's already set up
so that all the logs
that go to [? Foreground ?]
go to Stackdriver.
They're searchable.
You can output stuff.
So that's all
available to you just
as standard log aggregation.
And like I said in
the talk, standing
on the shoulders of giants.
That stuff we didn't have to do.
It's just great.
It's just there.
It's awesome.
And even in Agones itself we
actually spit out JSON logs.
So we do structured logging,
and that goes straight
into Stackdriver and
it's like, oh, it's JSON.
Awesome.
And now it's all searchable
and it's fantastic.
So I'm super happy.
It's not work we have to do.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: We have one
minute and 22 seconds.
No pressure.
Going once, going twice.
Awesome.
Well, again, thank you
so much for hanging out.
Stickers and business
cards are here.
And if you want to chat
more we'll be around at GDC.
So thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]